[Rires]
arrête un peu tout le temps
il y avait des meufs il y avait le choix
entre Mickey rourkey War et elle choisit
c'est toi
toi
tu as déjà eu une meuf elle est arrivée
comme ça entre toi et Mickey qu'elle t'a
choisi frère ça dépend de Los Angeles
monsieur
l'écran on va s'afficher l'adresse
d'optique 2000
le plus proche de chez elle c'était
avant les opérations esthétiques de
Gilbert Montagné
pas tout le temps on était dans les
mêmes soirées à l'hôtel au standard à
Los Angeles toi tu es au standard
[Applaudissements]
s
je suis dégoûté c'est encore gilberté
c'est encore Ken ma meuf
c'est un truc de ouf alors
il était avec Brad Pitt Tom Cruise le
truc il voyait tous il faut y arriver
j'y vais arriver merde on est mort
e qui va encore nous piquer nos meuf
dire il arrive ça va les mangas
mais dans
quelle ville comme ça parce que frère
taisez-vous
parce que cette émission est en train de
te rendre fou tout simplement
c'est pas possible mais qu'est-ce que tu
faisais là-bas
qu'est-ce qu'il fait
de quoi
vous voyez bien non mais raconte-nous
juste concrètement une histoire j'étais
en vacances à Auchan Los Angeles
[Applaudissements]
tu étais tout seul toi non j'étais avec
un collègue et Amir tous les ans pendant
10 ans
on avait nos habitudes on partait tous
les ans à Los Angeles on fait des
soirées dans les hôtels au Château
Marmont on allait souvent j'étais très
VIP au Château Marmont
il m'écrivait il m'écrivait encore tous
les ans pour me souhaiter la bonne année
mais c'est le grand jour
vous prenez pour quelqu'un de
dégueulasse et tout la merlok là
[Applaudissements]
j'arrive le plus bel hôtel de Los
Angeles
il y a que les vipères
c'est pas si cher au mois d'août c'est
pas si cher j'allais tous les ans
j'avais des prix c'était là-bas
c'est là où j'ai vécu toutes mes soirées
au quels sont les trucs que je peux pas
raconter en tracteur américain lucinant
comme elle j'étais VIP au château
Marmande et on allait faire des soirées
au standard ou Mickey Rourke était là
standard c'est quoi le standard c'est un
hôtel un autre hôtel de Los Angeles plus
moderne il y avait une soirée en bas et
parfois Mickey rourquette et tout et moi
et avec ma petite tête là comme ça et
bah c'est pas lui qui qui sortait
toujours avec les plus belles filles oui
monsieur ça a l'air de et tu t'es
réveillé à quelle heure
toute cette histoire parce que là c'est
parti
à New York et c'est vrai que je suis à
côté de petite française avec succès
même Molière là donc
j'étais très mal il a toujours été beau
il a toujours été dégueulasse
c'est pas vrai on peut mettre une photo
et vous allez voir qu'il est extrêmement
élégant
[Applaudissements]
que vous me fassiez un montage entre une
photo de Mickey
et vous allez juger par vous-même
il est arrivé déjà à mon avis il était
devant la boîte en train de jouer de la
guitare
arrête un peu qu'est-ce que tu as tapé
tu crois que les mecs entre Chantal Goya
et mikiro ça m'arrête et tu leur chant
des pancakes panda ou quoi là mettez-moi
kick là s'il vous plaît jeune parce que
c'était quelque chose aujourd'hui
maintenant elles sont rigoler on dirait
on dirait une chaloupe ah ouais bah
voilà non donc là donc là attendez donc
là je voudrais que vous fassiez à chaque
fois vous mettez la photographie donc là
tu arrives en boîte tu vois Mickey la
Mickey qui te Chine et là deux minutes
après tu as l'autre gars qui arrive
voilà merci voilà
il a une meuf il y a des meufs il y a
des meufs je vais partir avec le gars là
à mon avis
à l'époque
mais là frère donc là toi tu es accent
français
[Musique]
normalement des gars comme ça et tu
démarres comme ça il y a Christophe
Folin qui fait
[Musique]
Gilles Verdez
était connu au standard Los Angeles
[Rires]
Tom Cruise Brad Pitt très vite
il s'est cru au même niveau que
de conquête en conquête Gilles Verdez
est devenu celui qu'on lui surnommé à
Los Angeles le mythomane
aux chevaux gras
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alors le mythomane aux cheveux gras
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait alors là c'est
tout attends on a fini tes conneries
tout est vrai tout c'est vrai comment on
peut vérifier on va appeler Mickey
aujourd'hui il est là il est toujours de
la planète et enseignant maintenant
c'est toujours un ami on a écrit des
livres ensemble
Mikao qui se tapait les stars toi tu as
déjà chopé les stars ou pas franchement
c'était plutôt les mannequins russes
du pays
alors au début la soirée ils étaient
mannequin mais à quel moment tu euh je
suis allé à la tirette
[Applaudissements]
à quel moment tu sortais de la tomate
[Rires]
faire du roller à Malibu alors
le lendemain ils adoraient
que j'ai été un séducteur à un moment
faut l'avouer alors aujourd'hui tu es
magnifique je peux te dire que tu
pourrais séduire les plus belles mais
d'ailleurs fait tout est magnifique
quand on voit Fatou on se dit voilà
c'est vrai que là on s'est dit voilà on
se pose des questions tout simplement
c'est vrai qu'il y a pas que le physique
ah oui mais voilà
tu sais que ça peut plaire ça plaisait
non mais c'est rigoler oui quoi je
laisse la drogue est forte
c'est vrai que tu as raison